deadly riots over the government's plan
to avoid defaulting on its loans is that
the unemployment keeps rising and it has
to keep driving just because
this is all borrowed money debt is only
by banks in other countries
I can't filter cigarette that delivers
The Taste
malt liquor
is sponsor I first learned it from my
grandmother now my grandmother was a
wonderful person
she taught me how to play the game
Monopoly
she understood that the name of the game
is to acquire
she would accumulate everything she
could and eventually she became the
master of the board
and then she would always say the same
thing to me she'd look at me and she'd
say
one day you'll learn to play the game
one summer I played Monopoly almost
every day all day long and that summer I
learned to play the game
I came to understand the only way to win
is to make a total commitment to
acquisition I came to understand that
money and possessions that's the way
that you keep score
and by the end of that summer I was more
ruthless than my grandmother I was ready
to bend the rules if I had to to win
that game
and I sat down with her to play that
Fall
I took everything she had I watched her
give her last dollar and quit in utter
defeat
and then she had one more thing to teach
me
then she said
[Music]
now it all goes back in the box
all those houses and hotels
all the railroads and utility companies
all that property and all that wonderful
money
now it all goes back in the box
none of it was really yours
you got all heated up about it for a
while
but it was around a long time before you
sat down at the board
and it will be here after you're gone
players come and players go
houses and cars
titles and clothes
even your body
because the fact is that everything I
clutch and consume and hoard is going to
go back in the box and I'm going to lose
it all
you have to ask yourself when you
finally get the ultimate promotion when
you've made the ultimate purchase when
you buy the ultimate home when you have
stored up Financial Security and climbed
the ladder of success to the highest
rung you can possibly climb it
and the throwers off
and it will wear off
then what
how far do you have to walk down that
road before you see where it leads
[Music]
surely you understand
it'll never be enough
[Music]
so you have to ask yourself the question
what matters
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
foreign
growing up in New York City
I refused the pledge allegiance to the
flag
of course I was sent to the principal's
office
and he asked me why don't you want to
pledge allegiance everybody does I said
everybody wants to live here it was flag
but that doesn't make itself
I explained that America owed everything
it has to other cultures and other
nations and then I would rather pledge
allegiance to the Earth and everyone on
it
needless to say it wasn't long before I
left school entirely
and I set up a lab in my bedroom
there I began to learn about science and
nature I realized then that the universe
is governed by laws and that the human
being along with Society itself was not
exempt from these laws
then came the crash of 1929 which began
what we now call the Great Depression I
found it difficult to understand why
Millions were out of work homeless
starving while all the factories were
sitting there the resources were
unchanged it was then that I realized
that the rules of the economic game were
inherently invalid
shortly after came World War II were
various Nations took turns
systematically destroying each other
I later calculated that all the
destruction and wasted resources spent
on that war could have easily provided
for every human need on the planet
since that time I have watched Humanity
set the stage for its own Extinction
I have watched as a precious finite
resources of habitually wasted and
destroyed in the name of prophet and
free markets
I have watched the social values of
society be reduced into a base
artificiality of materialism and
Mindless consumption
and I have watched as the monetary
Powers control the political structure
of supposedly free societies
I'm 94 years old now and I'm afraid my
disposition is the same as it was 75
years ago
this shit's got to go
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
IST and somewhere along the way hammered
into your head is the inevitable nature
versus nurture and that's at least up
there with Coke versus Pepsi or Greeks
versus Trojans so nature versus nurture
this by now utterly oversimplifying view
of where influences are influences on
how a cell deals with an energy crisis
up to what makes us who we are and the
most individualistic levels of
Personality
um and what you've got is this complete
false dichotomy built around nature as
deterministic at the very bottom of all
the causality of life as DNA and the
code of codes and the Holy Grail and
everything's driven by it and at the
other end a much more social science
perspective which is we are social
organisms and biology is for slime molds
humans are free of biology and obviously
both views are nonsense what you see
instead is it is virtually impossible to
understand how biology Works outside the
context of environment
foreign
yet widespread and potentially dangerous
Notions is oh that behavior is genetic
now what does that mean it means all
sorts of subtle stuff if you sort of
know Modern Biology but for most people
out there what it winds up meaning is ah
a deterministic view of Life One rooted
in biology and genetics genes equal
things that can't be changed genes equal
things that are inevitable and that you
might as well not waste resources trying
to fix might as well not put societal
energies into try to improve because
it's inevitable it's unchangeable and
that is sheer nonsense
[Music]
it is widely thought that conditions
like ADHD are genetically programmed
conditions like schizophrenia are
genetically programmed the tooth is the
opposite nothing is genetically
programmed they're very rare diseases I
mean a small handful extremely
sparsely represented in the population
that are truly genetically determined
most complex conditions might have a
predisposition that a genetic component
but a predisposition is not the same as
a predetermination
the whole search for the source of
diseases in the genome I was doomed to
failure before anybody even thought of
it because most diseases are not
genetically predetermined heart disease
cancer Strokes
rheumatoid conditions autoimmune
conditions in general
mental health conditions addictions
these are none of them genetically
determined breast cancer for example out
of 100 women with breast cancer only
seven will carry the breast cancer genes
93 do not
and out of 100 women who do have the
genes not all don't get cancer
[Music]
not just things that make us behave in a
particular way regardless of our
environment
genes give us different ways of
responding to our environment
and in fact it looks as if some of the
Early Childhood influences of the kind
of child rearing
affects gene expression actually turning
on and off different genes to put you on
a different development developmental
track which may suit the kind of world
you've got to deal with so for example a
study done in Montreal with suicide
victims
looked at autopsies of the brains of
these people
and it turned out that if a suicide
victim these are usually young adults
had been abused as children the abuse
actually caused the genetic change in
the brain
that was absent in the brains of people
who had not been abused
that's an epigenetic effect Epi means on
top of so that so that the epigenetic
influence is what happens and
environmentally to either activate or
deactivate certain genes
in New Zealand there's a study that was
done in a town called Dunedin
in which uh a few thousand individuals
were studied from birth up to their into
their 20s
what they found was
that they could identify a genetic
mutation an abnormal Gene which
did have some relation to the
predisposition to commit violence
but only if the individual had also been
subjected to severe child abuse in other
words a child with this abnormal Gene
would be no more likely to be violent
than anybody else and in fact they
actually had a lower rate of violence
than people with normal genes as long as
they weren't abused as children
great additional example of the ways in
which genes are not be all end-all fancy
technique where you can take a specific
Gene out of a mouse that Mouse and this
descendants will not have that Gene you
have knocked out that Gene so there's
this one gene that codes for a protein
that has something to do with learning
and memory and this fabulous
demonstration knock out that Gene and
you have a mouse that doesn't learn as
well ooh a genetic basis for
intelligence what was much less
appreciated in that Landmark study that
got picked up by the media left and
right is take those genetically impaired
mice and raise them in a much more
enriched stimulating environment than
your normal mice in a lab cage and they
completely overcame that deficit
so when one says in the Contemporary
sense that oh this behavior is genetic
to the extent that that's even a valid
sort of phrase to use what you're saying
is there is a genetic contribution to
how this organism responds to
environment genes May influence the
Readiness with which an organism will
deal with a certain environmental
challenge you know that's not the
version most people have in their minds
and not to be too soapboxing but run
with the old sort of version of its
genetic and it's not that far from a
history of eugenics and things of that
sort
to widespread misconception and some
potentially fairly dangerous one
one reason that the
sort of biological explanation for
violence one reason that hypothesis is
potentially dangerous it's not just
misleading it can really do harm
is because if you believe that you could
very easily say well there's nothing we
can do to change the predisposition
people have to becoming violent all we
can do if somebody becomes violent is
punish them you know lock them up or
execute them but we don't need to worry
about changing the social environment or
the social preconditions that may lead
people to become violent because that's
irrelevant
the genetic argument allows us the
luxury of ignoring
past and present historical and social
factors and in the words of a Louis
Manas you wrote In The New Yorker very
astudely said it's on the genes an
explanation for the way things are that
does not threaten the way things are why
should someone feel unhappy or engage in
antisocial behavior when that person is
living in the freest and most prosperous
Nation on Earth it can't be the system
there must be a flaw in the wiring
somewhere
which is a good way of putting it so the
genetic argument is simply a cop-out
which allows us to ignore the social and
the economic and political factors that
in fact underlie
many Troublesome behaviors
[Music]
addictions are usually
considered to be a drug related issue
but looking at more broadly I Define
addiction as any Behavior
that is associated with craving with
temporary relief
and with long-term negative consequences
along with an impairment of control over
it so that the person wishes to give her
give it up or promises to do so but
can't follow through
and when you understand that then you
can see that there are many more
addictions than simply those related to
drugs there's workaholism there's
addition to shopping to the internet to
video games there's the addiction to
power people that have power but they
want more and more and more nothing is
ever enough for them acquisition
corporations that must own more and more
the addiction to oil or at least to the
wealth and to the products made
accessible To Us by oil look at the
negative consequences on the environment
uh we're destroying the very Earth that
we inhabit for the sake of that
addiction now these addictions are far
more devastating in their social
consequences than the cocaine or heroin
habits of my down to any side patients
yet they're rewarded
and considered to be respectable
the Tobacco Company executive that shows
a higher profit will get a much bigger
reward
he doesn't face any negative
consequences legally or otherwise in
fact he's a respected member of the
board of several other corporations
but tobacco smoke related diseases kill
five and a half million people around
the world every year
in the United States they killed 400 000
people a year
and these people are addicted to what to
profit to such a degree are they
addicted that they're actually in denial
about the impact of their activities
which is typical for addicts as denial
and that's irrespectable one it's
respectable to be addicted to profit no
matter what the cost
so what is acceptable and what is
respectable is a highly arbitrary
phenomenon in our society and it seems
like the greater the harm the more
respectable the addiction
[Music]
General myth that drugs in themselves
are addictive effective war and drugs is
predicated on the idea that if you
interdict the sources of drugs you can
deal with a dictionary
now um if you understand Addiction in a
brighter sense we see that nothing in
itself is addictive no substance no drug
is it by itself addictive and no
behaviors by itself addictive many
people can go shopping without becoming
shopaholics not everybody comes to food
addict not everyone who drinks a glass
of wine becomes an alcoholic so the real
issue is what makes people susceptible
because it's the combination of a
susceptible individual and the
potentially addictive substance or
behavior that actually then makes for
the for full flowering of addiction in
short it's not the drug that's addictive
it's the question of the susceptibility
individual to being addicted to
particular substance or behavior
if you wish to understand what that
makes us some people susceptible we
actually have to look at their life
experience the
old idea although it's old but it's
still broadly held that addictions are
due to some genetic cause it's simply
scientifically untenable
what the case is actually is that
certain life experiences make people
susceptible life experiences that not
only shape the person's
personality and and psychological needs
but also their very brains in certain
ways and that process begins in utero
[Music]
it's been shown for example that if you
stressed mothers during pregnancy
their children are more likely have
traits that be disposed them to
addictions and that's because
development is shaped by the
psychological and social environment so
the biology of human beings is very much
affected by and
programmed by their life experiences
beginning In Utero environment does not
begin at Birth environment begins as
soon as you have an environment as soon
as you repeat us you are subject to
whatever information is coming through
mom's circulations hormones levels of
nutrients great Landmark example of this
something called The Dutch hunger winter
1944 Nazis occupying Holland for a bunch
of reasons they decide to take all the
food and divert it to Germany for three
months everybody there is starving tens
of thousands of people starve to death
what the Dutch hunger winter effect is
if you were a second or third trimester
fetus during the starvation your body
learned something very unique during
that time as it turns out second third
trimester something that your body is
going about trying to learn about the
environment is well how menacing of a
place is it out there how plentiful how
how much nutrients am I getting by way
of Mom's circulation be a fetus who is
starving during that time and your body
programs Forever After to be really
really really stingy with your sugar and
fat and and what you do is you store
every bit of it be a Dutch hunger winter
fetus at half a century later everything
else being equal you are more likely to
have high blood pressure obesity or
metabolic syndrome that is environment
coming in a very unexpected place you
can stress animals in the laboratory
when they're pregnant and their
offspring will be more likely to use
cocaine and alcohol as adults
you can stress the human mothers for
example in a British study women who are
abused in pregnancy will have higher
levels of the stress hormone cortisol in
their placenta at Birth and their
children are more likely of conditions
that predisposal to addictions by age
seven or eight so you need to stress are
already prepares they're gone for all
kinds of mental health issues Israeli
study done prior on children born to
mothers who were pregnant prior to the
onset of the 1967 war
these women of course are very stressed
and their offspring have a higher
incidence of schizophrenia than the
average Accord
so there's plenty of evidence now that
prenatal effects have a huge impact on
the developing human being
the point about human development and
specifically specifically in brain
development is that it occurs mostly
under the impact of the environment and
mostly after birth now if you compare us
to a horse which can run on the first
day of life we see that we are very
undeveloped we can't develop we can't uh
Muster that much neurological
coordination balance muscle strength
visual Acuity until a year and a half
two years and that's because the brain
development that in the horse happens in
the safety of the womb in a human being
has to happen after birth and that has
to do with simple evolutionary logic as
the head gets larger which is what makes
us into human beings the burgeoning of
the forebrain is what creates the human
species actually at the same time I walk
on two legs so our pelvis Narrows to
come at that so now we have a narrower
pelvis a larger head Bingo we have to be
born prematurely and that means that the
brain development that in other animals
occurs in euro in US occurs after birth
and much of that under the impact of the
environment and the concept of neural
Darwinism simply means that the circuits
that get the appropriate input from the
environment will develop optimally and
the ones that don't will either not
develop optimally or perhaps not at all
if you take a child with perfectly good
eyes at Birth you put in the dark room
for five years he'll be blind thereafter
for the rest of his life because the
circuits of vision require light waves
for their development and without that
even the rudimentary circuits present
and active at Birth will atrophy and die
and humans will not develop
there's a significant way in which early
experiences shape adult Behavior
and even and especially early
experiences for which there's no recall
memory
it turns out that there are two kinds of
memory there is explicit memory which is
recall this is when you can call back
fact details episodes
circumstances but the structure in the
brain which is called the hippocampus
which encodes vehicle memory it doesn't
even begin to develop fully until a year
and a half and it's not fully developed
or much later which is why hardly
anybody has any vehicle memory prior to
18 months but there's another kind of
memory which is called the implicit
memory which is in fact an emotional
memory
where the emotional impact and the
interpretation that the child makes of
those emotional experiences is ingrained
in the brain in the form of nerve
circuits ready to fire without specific
recall so give you a clear example
people who are adopted have a lifelong
sense of rejection very often
they can't recall the adoption they
can't recall the separation of the earth
mother but there's nothing there to
recall with but the emotional memory of
separation and rejection is deeply
embedded in their brains hence they're
much more likely to experience a sense
of rejection and a great emotional upset
when they perceive themselves as being
rejected than other people that's not
unique to people who are adopted but
it's particularly strong in them because
of this function of implicit memory
people who are addicted given that they
according to all the research literature
certainly in my experience the hardcore
addicts are virtually were all
significantly abuse these children or
suffered severe emotional loss their
emotional or implicit memories are those
of a world that's not safe and not not
helpful caregivers or not to be trusted
and relationships that are not safe
enough to open up to vulnerably and has
their responses tend to be to keep them
stuff separate from really intimate
relationships not to trust caregivers
doctors and other people who are trying
to help them and generally see the world
as an unsafe place and that's strictly a
function of implicit memory which
sometimes has to do with incidents they
don't even recall
[Music]
infants were born premature are often in
incubators and in various types of
gadgetry and machinery for weeks and
perhaps months
it's not known that if these children
are touched and stroked on the back for
just 10 minutes a day that promotes
their brain development
so human touch is essential for
development and in fact infants were
never picked up will actually die
that's how much of a fundamental need
being held is to human beings in our
society there's an unfortunate tendency
to tell parents not to pick up their
kids not to hold them not to
pick up babies who are crying for fear
of spoiling them or
to encourage them to sleep through the
night you don't pick them up which which
is just the opposite of what the child
needs and these children might go back
to sleep because they give up
and everything's just shut down in the
way of
defending against the vulnerability of
being abandoned really by their parents
but their implicit memories will be that
of a world that doesn't give a damn
a lot of these differences are
structured very early in life in a way
the if you like the parental experience
of adversity how tough life is or how
easy it is is passed on to children
whether through maternal depression or
parents being bad tempered with their
kids because they've had a hard day or
just being too tired at the end of the
day
and these have very powerful effects
programming children's development which
we know a lot about now
but that's early sensitivity isn't just
an evolutionary mistake it exists again
in many different species even seedlings
as an early adaptive process to the kind
of environment they're growing up in but
for humans the adaptation is to the
quality of social relations
and so early life how nurturing or how
much conflict how much attention you get
is a taster of the kind of world you may
be growing up in are you growing up in a
world where you have to fight for what
you can get watch your back fend for
yourself learn not to trust others
why are you growing up in a society
where you depend on reciprocity
mutuality cooperation where empathy is
important where your security depends on
good relations with other people and
that needs a very different emotional
and cognitive development and that's
what the early sensitivity is about and
parenting is almost quite unconsciously
a system for passing on that experience
to Children of the kind of world they're
in
the Great British child psychiatrist DW
unicott said that fundamentally two
things can go wrong in childhood one is
when things happen that shouldn't happen
and then things that should happen but
don't in the first category is the
traumatic and abusive and abandonment
experiences of my downtown Eastside
patients and of many addicts that's what
shouldn't happen but did
but then there is the
non-stressed attuned non-distracted
attention of the parent that every child
needs
that very often children don't get
they're not abused they're not neglected
and and they're not traumatized
but what should happen the presence of
the emotionally available nurturing
brand to which it is not available to
them because of the stresses in our
society and the parenting environment
and the psychologists
Alan Shore calls that proximal
abandonment when the present the parent
is physically present but emotionally
absent
I have spent uh
oh roughly the last 40 years of my life
working with the most violent
people our society produces murderers
rapists and so on in an attempt to
understand what causes this violence
I discovered that the most violent of
the criminals in our prisons
had themselves been victims
of a degree of child abuse that was
beyond the scale of what I ever thought
of applying the term child abuse to I
had no idea
of the depth of the depravity with which
children in our society are all too
often treated the most violent people I
saw were themselves the survivors of
their own attempted murder often at the
hands of their parents or other people
in their social impairment or were the
survivors of family members have been
killed their closest family members by
other people
the Buddha argued that everything
depends on everything else
he says that one contains the many and
the many contains the one that you can't
understand anything in isolation from
its environment the leaf contains the
sun the sky and the Earth obviously
uh
this has not been shown to be true of
course all around and specifically when
it comes to human development
the modern scientific term for it is the
biopsychosocial nature of human
development which says that the biology
of human beings depends very much on
their interaction with the social and
psychological environment and
specifically the psychiatrist and
researcher
Daniel Siegel at the University of
California Los Angeles UCLA has coined
the phrase interpersonal neurobiology
which means to say that the way that our
nervous system functions
depends very much on our personal
relationships in the first place with
the parenting caregivers and in the
second place with other important
attachment figures in our lives and in
the third place with our entire culture
so that you can't separate the
neurological functioning of a human
being from the environment in which he
or she grew up in and continues to exist
in and this is true throughout the life
cycle it's particularly true when you're
dependent and helpless and your brain is
developing but it's too even in adults
and even at the end of life
[Music]
human beings have lived in almost every
kind of society from the most
egalitarian hunting and Gathering
societies seem to have been very
egalitarian for instance based on food
sharing gift exchange
small bands of people living
predominantly off of foraging but a
little bit of hunting predominantly
among people you have at the least known
your entire life if not surrounded by
third cousins or closer in a world in
which there is a great deal of fluidity
between different groups and World in
which there is not a whole lot in terms
of material culture this is how humans
have spent most of their hominid history
and no surprise that makes for a very
different world one of the things you
get as a result of that is far less
violence organized group violence is not
something that occurred at that time
it seems quite clear
so where did we go wrong
violence is not
uh Universal it's not symmetrically
distributed throughout the human race
there is a huge variation in the amount
of violence and differences
there are some societies that have
virtually no violence there are others
that destroy themselves some of the
anabaptist
religious groups that are complete and
strict pacifists like the Amish the
Mennonites the Hutterites among some of
these groups the Hutterites there are no
recorded cases of homicide
during our major Wars like World War II
where people were being drafted they
would refuse to serve in the military
they would go to prison rather than
serve in the military in the kobutsu in
Israel the level upon us is so low that
the criminal courts there will often
send violent offenders people have
committed crimes to live on the cubism
in order to learn how to live a
non-violent life because that's the way
people live there so we are amply shaped
by Society our Societies in the broader
sense including our theological or
metaphysical or linguistic influences
Etc our societies helped shape us as to
whether or not we think life is
basically about sin or about beauty
whether the afterlife will carry a price
for how we live our lives or if it's
irrelevant
in a broad sort of way different large
societies could be termed as
individualistic or collectivist and you
get very different people in different
mindsets and I suspect different brains
coming along with that we in America are
in one of the most individualistic of
societies and capitalism being a system
that allows you to go higher and higher
up a a potential pyramid and the deal is
it comes with fewer and fewer safety
nets by definition the more stratified a
society is the fewer people you have as
peers the fewer people with whom you
have symmetrical reciprocal
relationships and instead all you have
are differing spots and endless
hierarchies and a world in which you
have few reciprocal Partners as a world
with a lot less altruism
foreign
possible juncture which is to try to
make sense in perspective science as to
what the nature is of human nature you
know on a certain level
the nature of our nature is not to be
particularly constrained by our nature
we come up with more social variability
than any species out there more systems
of belief of styles of family structures
of ways of raising children the capacity
for variety that we have is
extraordinary
in a society which is predicated on
competition
and really
very often the ruthless exploitation
of one human being by another the
profiteering of other people's problems
and very often
the creation of problems for the purpose
of profiteering
the ruling ideology will very often
justify that behavior by appeals to some
fundamental and unalterable Human Nature
so the myth in our society is that
people are competitive by nature and
that they're individualistic and that
they're selfish
the real uh reality is quite the
opposite we have certain human needs the
only way that you can talk about human
nature concretely is by recognizing that
there's certain human needs we have a
human need for companionship and for
close contact to be loved to be attached
to to be accepted to be seen to be
received for who we are
if those needs are met we develop and
two people who are compassionate and
cooperative and and to have empathy for
other people
so
the opposite that we often see in our
society is in fact the Distortion of
human nature precisely because so few
people have their needs met
so yes you can talk about human nature
but only in the sense of basic human
needs that are instinctively evoked or I
should say certain human needs that lead
to certain traits if they are met in a
different set of traits if they're
denied
so
when we recognize the fact that the
human organism which has a great deal of
adaptive flexibility allowing us to
survive in many different conditions
is also rigidly programmed for certain
and environmental requirements or human
needs a social imperative begins to
emerge
just as our bodies require physical
nutrients the human brain demands
positive forms of environmental stimulus
at all stages of development
while also needing to be protected from
other negative forms of stimulus
and if things that should happen do not
or things that shouldn't happen due it
is now apparent that the door can be
opened for not only a Cascade of mental
and physical diseases
but many detrimental human behaviors as
well
so as we turn our perspective now
outward and take account for the State
of Affairs today we must ask the
question
is the condition we have created in the
modern world actually supporting our
health
is the Bedrock of our socioeconomic
system acting as a positive force for
human and Social Development and
progress
or is the foundational gravitation of
our society actually going against the
core evolutionary requirements needed to
create and maintain our personal and
social well-being
thank you
so one might ask where did this all
begin what we have today really a world
in a state of accumulative collapse
you get it started with John Locke and
John Locke introduces property and has
Street Provisions for just private right
and property and the three provisos are
that there must be enough left over for
others and that she must not let it
spoil and that you most of all must mix
your labor with it
seems Justified she makes your labor
with the world then you're entitled to
the product and as long as there's
enough left over for others and as long
as it doesn't spoil you don't allow
anything to go to waste that's okay well
he spends a long time of his famous
Treatise of government and it's since
been the canonical text for economic and
political and legal understanding is
still at the classic Texas study well
what he did is it after he gives the
provisos and you're almost thinking at
the time whether you're for private
property or not he's given a very a very
good and plausible and Powerful defense
of private property here well he drops
them he drops them like that right in
one sentence he says well once the
introduction of money came in by men's
tacit consent then it became and he
doesn't say all the provisos are
canceled erased but that's what happens
so now we have not product in your
property earned by your own labor oh no
money buys labor now
there's no longer a consideration of
whether there's enough left over for
others there's no longer a consideration
of whether it spoils because he says
well money's like silver and gold and
gold can't spoil therefore monies can't
be responsible for Waste which is
ridiculous we're not talking about money
and silver we're talking about what its
effects are it's one non-sequitur after
another just the most uh startling
logical Ledger domain that he gets away
with here but it fits the interests of
capital owners
then Adam Smith comes along and what he
adds is the religion to this lock
started with God made it all this way
this is God's right and now we get also
with Smith coming along he says it's not
only God's I mean he's not saying this
but this is what's happening
philosophically being principle he's
saying it's not only a question of
private property that's all now
presupposed is given and that there's
money investors that buy labor given
that there's no limit to how much they
can buy of other men's labor how much
they can accumulate how much inequality
that's all given them
and so he comes along and what his big
idea is and again it's just introduced
them in parenthesis on on Passau you
know when people put out the goods for
sale and others you know the supply and
other people buy them with the demand
and so forth how do you how do we have
Supply equaling demand or demand
equaling Supply how can they come into
equilibrium and that is one of the
central Notions of Economics is how do
they come into equilibrium and he says
it's the Invisible Hand of the market
that brings him into equilibrium so now
we have God is actually imminent he just
didn't give the rights to property and
how uh you know all it's wherewithal and
uh its natural rights of doing all the
lock said now we have the system itself
as God
in fact Smith says when he talks and
you'll never find this quote again I
have to read the whole of the inquiry
into The Wealth of Nations he says the
scantiness of subsistence sets limits to
the reproduction of the poor and that
nature can deal with this in no other
way than elimination of their children
so he anticipated evolutionary theory in
the worst sense I applied this as well
before Darwin and so he he called them
the race of laborers so you can see
there was inherent racism built in here
there was an inherent acceptance life
blindness to kill
in innumerable children
and he thought well that's the Invisible
Hand making Supply meet demanded the
man-made Supply so see what how wise God
is
so you can see a lot of the really very
this life destructive
Eco genocidal things that are going on
now have in a way a thought Gene back in
Smith too
when we reflect on the original concept
of the so-called free market capitalist
system as initiated by early economic
philosophers such as Adam Smith we see
that the original intent of a market was
based around real tangible
life-supporting goods for trade Adam
Smith Never fathomed that the most
profitable economic sector on the planet
would eventually be in the arena of
financial trading or so-called
investment or money itself is simply
gained by the movement of other money in
an arbitrary game which holds zero
productive Merit to society
yet regardless of Smith's intent the
door for such seemingly anomalous
advents was left wide open by one
fundamental tenet of this Theory money
is treated as a commodity in and of
itself
today in every economy of the world
regardless of the social system they
claim money is pursued for the sake of
money and nothing else
the underlying idea which was
mysteriously qualified by Adam Smith
with his religious Declaration of the
Invisible Hand
is that the narrow self-interested
pursuit of this fictional commodity will
somehow magically manifest human and
social well-being and progress
the reality is that the monetary
incentive interest or what some have
termed the money sequence of value has
now completely decoupled from the
foundational life interest which could
be termed the life sequence of value
what has happened is that there's a
complete confusion in economic Doctrine
between those two sequences they think
that the money sequence of value
delivers the life sequence of value that
and that's why they say if more goods
are sold if gdps rise and so forth
therefore there'd be more well-being
enhanced well-being we take the GDP to
be our basically our indicator of social
health well there you see the confusion
is talking about money sequences the
value that is all the receipts all the
revenues that are derived from selling
goods and they're confusing that with
life reproduction so that you have built
right into this thing from the beginning
is a complete conflation of the money
and life sequences of value so we're
dealing with a kind of structured
delusion that becomes more and more
deadly as the money sequence decouples
from producing anything at all so it's a
system disorder and the system disorder
seems to be fatal
in society today you seldom hear anyone
speak of the progress of their country
or Society in terms of their physical
well-being state of Happiness trust or
social stability
rather the measures are presented to us
through economic abstractions we have
the gross domestic product the Consumer
Price Index the value of the stock
market rates of inflation and so on
but does this tell us anything of real
value as to the quality of people's
lives
no all these measures have to do with
the money sequence itself and nothing
more
for example the gross domestic product
of a country is a measure of the value
of goods and services sold
this measure is claimed to correlate to
the standard of living of a country's
people
in the United States Health Care
accounted for over 17 percent of GDP in
2009 amounting to over 2.5 trillion
spent hence creating a positive effect
on this economic measure and based on
this logic it would be even better for
the U.S economy if Health Care Services
increased more so perhaps to three
trillion dollars or 5 trillion since
that would create more growth more jobs
and hence boasted by economists as a
rise in their country's standard of
living
but wait a minute what do Health Care
Services actually represent
well sick and dying people
that's right the more unhealthy people
there are in America the better the
economy
now that is not an exaggeration or a
cynical perspective in fact if we step
back far enough you will realize that
the GDP not only doesn't reflect real
public or social health on any tangible
level it is in fact mostly a measure of
industrial inefficiency and social
degradation and the more you see it rise
the worse things are becoming with
respect to personal social and
environmental integrity
you have to create problems to create
profit
there is no profit under the current
Paradigm in Saving Lives putting balance
on this planet having Justice and peace
or anything else there's just no profit
there
is an old saying pass a law create a
business
whether you're creating a business for a
lawyer or whatever so you know crime
does create business just like
destruction creates it creates business
in Haiti we have now roughly two million
people in incarcerated in this country
and of those many of them are in prisons
run by private corporations Corrections
Corporation of America wackenhout who
trade their stock on Wall Street based
upon how many people are in jail
now that's sickness but that is a
reflection of what this economic
Paradigm calls for
so what exactly does this economic
Paradigm call for
what is it that keeps our economic
system going
consumption
or more accurately cyclical consumption
when we break down the foundation of
classic market economics we are left
with a pattern of monetary exchange that
simply cannot be allowed to stop or even
substantially slowed if the society as
we know it is to remain operational
there are three main actors on the
economic stage the employee the employer
and the consumer the employee sells
labor to the employer for income the
employer sells its Production Services
and hence Goods to the consumer for
income and the consumer of course is
simply another role of the employer and
employee spending back into the system
to enable the cyclical consumption to
continue in other words the global
market system is based on the assumption
that there will always be enough product
demand in society to move enough money
around at a rate which can keep the
consumption process going and the faster
the rate of consumption the more
so-called economic growth is assumed and
so the machine goes
but hold on
I thought an economy was meant to I
don't know economize doesn't the very
term have to do with preservation and
efficiency and a reduction of waste so
how does our system which demands
consumption and the more the better
efficiently preserve or economize at all
it doesn't
the intent of the market system is in
fact the exact opposite of what a real
economy is supposed to do which is
efficiently and conservatively Orient
the materials for production and
distribution of life-supporting goods
we live on a finite planet with finite
resources where for example the oil we
utilize took millions of years to
develop where the minerals we used took
billions of years to develop
so having a system that deliberately
promotes the acceleration of consumption
for the sake of so-called economic
growth is pure ecocidal insanity
absence of waste that's what efficiency
is absence of waste this system is more
wasteful than all the other existing
systems in the history of the planet
every level of Life organization and
life system is in a state of Crisis and
Challenge and Decay or collapse no peer
review journal in the last 30 years will
tell you anything different that is that
every life system is in Decline as well
as social programs as well as our water
access and try to name any means of life
that isn't threatened and in danger
you can there isn't there really isn't
one and that's very very despairing but
we haven't even figured out the causal
mechanism we don't want to face the
causal mechanism we just want to go on
you know that's what insanity is where
you keep doing the same thing over and
over again though it clearly doesn't
work
so you're really
dealing with not an economic system but
I would go so far as to say an
anti-economic system
[Music]
there's an old saying that the
competitive market model seeks to create
the best possible Goods at the lowest
possible prices
this statement is essentially the
incentive concept which justifies Market
competition based on the assumption that
the result is the production of higher
quality Goods
if I was going to build myself a table
from scratch I would naturally build it
out of the best most durable materials
possible Right with the intent for it to
last as long as possible why would I
want to make something poor knowing I
would have to eventually do it again and
expend more materials and more energy
well as rational as that may seem in the
physical world when it comes to the
market world it is not only explicitly
irrational it is not even an option
it is technically impossible to produce
the best of anything if a company is to
maintain a Competitive Edge and hence
remain affordable to the consumer
literally everything created and set for
sale in the global economy is
immediately inferior the moment it is
produced for it is a mathematical
impossibility to make the most
scientifically Advanced efficient and
strategically sustainable products this
is due to the fact that the market
system requires that cost efficiency or
the need to reduce expenses exist at
every stage of production from the cost
of Labor to the cost of materials and
packaging and so on
this competitive strategy of course is
to make sure the public buys their goods
rather than from a competing producer
which is doing the exact same thing to
also make their goods both competitive
and affordable
this immutably wasteful consequence of
the system could be termed intrinsic
obsolescence
however this is only one part of a
larger problem a fundamental governing
principle of market economics one that
you will not find in any textbook by the
way is the following nothing produced
can be allowed to maintain a lifespan
longer than what can be endured in order
to continue cyclical consumption
in other words it is critical that stuff
break down fail and expire within a
certain amount of time
this is termed planned obsolescence
planned obsolescence is the backbone of
the underlying Market strategy of every
Goods producing Corporation in existence
while a very few of course would admit
to such a strategy outright what they do
is mask it within the intrinsic
obsolescence phenomenon just discussed
while often ignoring or even suppressing
new advents in technology which might
create a more sustainable durable good
so if it wasn't wasteful enough that the
system inherently cannot allow the most
durable and efficient Goods to be
produced planned obsolescence
deliberately recognizes that the longer
any good is in operation the worse it is
for sustaining cyclical consumption and
hence the market system itself
in other words product sustainability is
actually inverse to economic growth and
hence there is a direct reinforced
incentive to make sure life spans are
short of Any Given good produced
and in fact the system cannot operate
any other way
one glance at the Sea of landfills now
spreading across the world show the
obsolescence reality there are now
billions of cheaply made cell phones
computers and other technology each full
of precious difficult to mine materials
such as gold Colt and copper now rotting
in vast piles usually due to the mere
malfunction or obsolescence of small
parts which in a conservative Society
could likely be fixed or updated and the
life of the good extended
unfortunately as efficient as that may
seem in our physical reality living on a
finite planet with finite resources it
is explicitly inefficient with respect
to the market
to put it into a phrase efficiency
sustainability and preservation are the
enemies of our economic system
likewise just as physical Goods need to
be constantly produced and reproduced
regardless of their environmental impact
the service industry operates with an
equal rationale
the fact is there is no monetary benefit
to resolving any problems which are
currently being serviced at the end of
the day the last thing the medical
establishment really wants is the curing
of diseases such as cancer which would
eliminate countless jobs and trillions
in Revenue
and since we're on the subject crime and
terrorism in this system are good
well at least economically Ford is
employing police generating high-value
commodities for security not to mention
the value of Prisons that are privately
owned for-profit
and how about war the War Industry in
America is a huge driver of GDP one of
the most profitable Industries producing
weapons of death and destruction
the favorite game of this industry is to
blow things up and then go and rebuild
them for profit we saw this with the
windfall billion dollar contracts made
from the Iraq War
the bottom line is that socially
negative attributes of society have
become positively rewarded Ventures for
industry and any interest in problem
resolution or environmental
sustainability and conservation is
intrinsically counter to economic
sustainability
and this is why every time you see the
GDP rise in any country you are
witnessing an increase in necessity
whether real or contrived and by
definition a necessity is rooted in
inefficiency hence increased necessity
means increased inefficiency
[Music]
the American dream is based on rampant
consumerism it is based upon the fact
that mainstream media and especially
commercial advertising all corporations
who need this infinite growth have
convinced us or brainwashed most people
in America and hence the world that we
have to have X number of material
possessions and the possibility of
gaining infinitely more material
possessions in order to be happy that's
just not true so how why do people
continue to to buy in this way which is
ultimately equal genocidal in its
systemic effects cumulatively and it
just is classical operant conditioning
you simply put inputs of conditioning
into the organism and you have outputs
of desired behaviors or goals or
objectives and it has all the resources
of technology and they post about how
they get into the minds of infants what
they hear is already making them
conditioned to the brand
then you see well that's how people have
been such fools in a way they've been
taught to be fools it's a value system a
disorder
you know if there is any Testament to
the plasticity of the human mind if
there is any proof to how malleable
human thought is and how easily
conditioned and guided people can become
based on the nature of their
environmental stimulus and what it
reinforces
the world of commercial advertising is
the proof
you have to stand in awe at the level of
brainwashing where these programmed
robots known as consumers wander the
landscape only to walk into a store and
spend say four thousand dollars on a
handbag that likely costs ten dollars to
make in a sweatshop overseas only for
the brand status it supposedly
represents in the culture
or perhaps the ancient communal
Traditions which increase trust and
cohesiveness in society which have now
been hijacked by acquisitive
materialistic values where now annually
we exchange useless crap a few times a
year
and we might wonder why so many today
have a compulsion to shopping in
acquisition when it is clear that they
have been conditioned from childhood to
expect material Goods as a sign of their
status with friends and family
the fact is the foundation of any
society are the values that support its
operation and our society as it exists
can only operate if our values support
the conspicuous consumption it requires
to continue the market system
75 years ago consumption in America and
much of the first world was half of what
we see today per person
today's new consumer culture has been
manufactured and imposed due to the very
real need for higher and higher levels
of consumption
and this is why most corporations now
spend more money on Advertising than the
actual process of product creation
itself they work diligently to create a
false need for you to fill
and it happens to work
you know economists in fact not
economists at all they're propagandists
of money value and you'll find that all
their models basically get down to token
exchanges that are to the profit of one
side or both sides or whatever but
they're completely disconnected from the
actually existing world of reproduction
and in Ohio an old man failed to pay his
electric bill you may be familiar with
the case and the electric company turned
off the electricity and he died the
reason they turned it off was because it
wouldn't have been profitable for them
to keep it on because he didn't pay his
bill
do you believe that was right the
responsibility really lies not on the
electric company for turning it off
but on those of this man's neighbors and
friends and Associates who are not
charitable enough to enable him as an
individual to meet the electric bill
hmm
did I hear that right
did he just say the death of a man
caused by not having money was the
responsibility of other people or in
effect charity
well then I guess we're going to need a
whole lot of infomercials a little
miserable coin slot donations for Bodega
counters and a bunch of pickle jars for
the billion people now starving to death
on this planet because of the various
system Milton Friedman promotes
whether you are dealing with the
philosophies of Milton Friedman f.a
Hayek John Maynard Keynes Ludwig von
mises or any other major Market
Economist the basis of rationale rarely
leaves the money sequence
it is like a religion consumption
analysis stabilization policies deficit
spending aggregate demand
it exists as a never-ending
self-referring
self-rationalizing circle of discourse
where Universal human need natural
resources or any form of physical
life-supporting efficiency is ruled out
by default and replaced by the singular
notion that humans seek an advantage
over each other for money alone
motivated by their own narrow
self-interest will magically create a
sustainable healthy balanced Society
there is no life coordinate in this
whole Theory this whole Doctrine what
are they doing what are they doing what
they're doing is tracking money
sequences that's all it is is tracking
money sequences presupposing
everything that matters one that there's
no life coordinates wow no life
coordinates
two that all the agents are
self-maximizing preference Seekers
that is they think of nothing other than
themselves and what they can get most
for themselves that that note that
seduction that's the ruling notion of
rationality
self-maximizing choice and and the only
thing that there's interested in
self-maximizing is money or commodities
well where does social relations come in
it doesn't accept in the exchange to
self-maximize where do our natural
resources come in they don't except to
exploit where
does the family come in as being able to
survive it doesn't they have to have
money in order to purchase any good well
shouldn't an economy deal somewhere with
human need isn't that what to
fundamental issue is to satisfy our
human needs oh need isn't even in your
Lexicon
uh you dissolve into wants and what does
it want that means money demand that
wants to buy
well if it's funny when a man to Monster
by it's got nothing to do with me
because it may be the person has no
money to man and desperately needs to
say water supply
or it may be money demand wants a gold
toilet seat well where does it all go to
the gold toilet seat and you call this
economics like it's reading when one
thinks of it it's got to be the most
bizarre
uh delusion in the history of human
thought
foreign
we have focused on the market system but
this system is actually only one half of
the global economic Paradigm the other
half is the monetary system while the
market system deals with the interaction
of people gaming for profit across the
spectrum of Labor production and
distribution the monetary system is an
underlying set of policies set by
financial institutions which create
conditions for the market system among
other things it includes terms we often
hear such as interest rates loans debt
the money supply inflation
Etc
and while you might want to pull your
hair out listening to the gibberish
coming from the monetary economists
modest preemptive actions can obviate
the need of more drastic actions at a
later date the nature and effect of this
system is actually quite simple
our economy has or the global economy
has three basic things the governor one
is fractional Reserve banking but Banks
printing money out of nothing
it's also based upon compound interest
when you borrow money you have to pay
back more than you borrowed which means
that you in effect create money
out of thin air again which has to be
serviced by creating still more money we
live in an infinite growth Paradigm the
economic Paradigm we live in now is is a
Ponzi scheme it's nothing grows forever
it's not possible as a great uh
psychologist James Hillman wrote the
only thing that grows in a human body
after a certain age is cancer
it's not just the amount of money that
has to keep growing it's the amount of
consumers consumers to borrow money at
interest to generate more money and
obviously that's not possible on a
finite planet
people are basically vehicles to just
create money which must create more
money to keep the whole thing from
falling apart which is what's happening
right now
there are really only two things anyone
needs to know about the monetary system
one all money is created out of debt
money is monetized debt whether it
materialized from treasury Bonds home
loan contracts or credit cards in other
words if all outstanding debt was to be
repaid right now there would not be one
dollar in circulation
and two interest is charged on virtually
all loans made
and the money needed to pay back this
interest does not exist in the money
supply outright only the principal is
created by the loans and the principle
is the money supply
so if all this debt was to be repaid
right now Not only would there not be
one dollar left in circulation there
would also be a gigantic amount of money
owed that is literally impossible to pay
back for it does not exist
the consequence of all of this is that
two things are inevitable
inflation and bankruptcy
as far as inflation this can be seen as
an historical Trend in virtually every
country today and easily tied to its
cause which is the Perpetual increase of
the money supply which is required to
cover the interest charges and keep the
system going
as far as bankruptcy it comes in the
form of debt collapse
this collapse will inevitably occur with
a person a business or a country and
typically happens when the interest
payments are no longer possible to make
but there is a bright side of all of
this well at least in terms of the
market system
because debt creates pressure debt
creates wage slaves a person in debt is
much more likely to take a low wage than
a person who isn't hence becoming a
cheap commodity so it's great for the
corporations to have a pool of people
that have no Financial Mobility
but hey that same train of thought also
goes for entire countries
the World Bank and the international
monetary fund which mostly serve as
proxies for transnational corporate
interests give gigantic loans to
troubled countries at very high interest
rates and then once the countries are
deeply in the whole and can't pay
austerity measures are applied the
corporations swoop in set up sweatshops
and take their natural resources
now that's market efficiency
but wait there's more you see there's
this unique hybrid of the monetary and
market system called the stock market
which rather than you know actually
produce anything real they just buy and
sell money itself
and when it comes to debt you know what
they do
that's right they traded
they actually buy and sell debt for
profit
from credit default swaps and
collateralized debt obligations for
Consumer Debt to complex derivative
schemes used to mask the debt of entire
countries such as the collusion of
Investment Bank Goldman Sachs and Greece
which nearly collapsed the entire
European economy
so when it comes to the stock market and
Wall Street we have an entirely new
level of insanity born out of the money
sequence of value
all you need to know about markets was
written in an editorial in the Wall
Street Journal a couple years ago it was
called lessons of the brain damaged
investor and in this editorial they
explain why people with slight brain
damage do better as investors than
people with normal brain functionality
why because the slightly brain damaged
person has no empathy and that's the key
if you don't have any empathy you do
well as an investor and so Wall Street
breeds people who have no empathy to go
in there and to make decisions and make
trades that they have no compunction
about and no thought whatsoever as that
what they're doing might affect their
fellow human being so they breed these
robots these these people have no souls
and since they don't even want to pay
these people anymore they're now
breeding robots real robots real
algorithmic Traders uh Goldman Sachs and
the high frequency trading Scandal they
put a computer next to the change the
New York Stock Exchange this computer
this code located computer as they call
it it front runs all the trades on the
exchange and it hits the exchanges with
volumes of orders in ways that Scout
pennies and nickels away from the
exchange it's just it's like they're
siphoning money all day long they want
one quarter last year 30 or 60 straight
days without a single down day and made
millions of dollars every single day is
that because well that's statistically
impossible
when I worked on Wall Street the way it
works is everyone kicks upstairs the
bribes the Brokers bribe to the
office manager the office manager bribes
to the regional sales manager the
regional sales manager bribes of the
national sales manager it's a common
understanding at Christmas who gets the
biggest bonus at Christmas in an average
brokerage office the compliance officer
the compliance officer sits there all
day long he's supposed to be making sure
you don't violate any of the margin
rules and you're complying with the law
of course yeah to the extent that you
can broad the compliance officer yeah
that's right you are complying with the
law so how does fraud has become the
system it's no longer a byproduct
it is the system you know it's like that
old Woody Allen joke he says Doctor my
brother thinks he's a chicken and the
doctor says take a pill and that should
cure the problem and he says no doctor
you don't understand we need the eggs
Okay so
the trading of fraudulent claims back
and forth between Banks
to generate fees to generate bonuses has
become the GDP
producing growth engine of the United
States economy even though they're
essentially trading fraudulent claims
that there's absolutely no hope of ever
paying back they're processing and
generating and re-securitizing nothing
if I write 20 billion dollars on a
cocktail napkin and I sell to JP Morgan
while JP Morgan writes 20 billion
dollars on a cocktail napkin and we
swapped those two cocktail napkins at a
bar and we each pay ourselves a quarter
of one percent in the fee and we make a
lot of money for our Christmas bonus we
each have on our books the 20 billion
dollar cocktail napkin which has no real
value until such time as the system is
no longer able to absorb bogus cocktail
napkins in which case we go to the
government to get bailed out
and because of Wall Street and the
global stock market there are now
conservatively about 700 trillion
dollars of outstanding fraudulent claims
known as derivatives still waiting to
collapse a value amounting to over 10
times the gross domestic product of the
entire planet
and while we have seen the bailouts of
Corporations and banks by governments
which of course comedically borrowed
their money from Banks to begin with
we are now seeing attempts to bail out
whole countries by a conglomerates of
other countries through the
International Banks
but how do you bail out a planet
there is no country out there that isn't
now saturated in debt the Cascade of
sovereign debt defaults we have seen can
only be the beginning when the math is
taken into account
it has been estimated in the United
States alone that income tax would need
to be raised to 65 percent per person
just to cover the interest in the near
future
economists are now foreshadowing that
within a few decades 60 percent of the
countries on the planet will be bankrupt
but hold on let me get this straight
the world is going bankrupt whatever the
hell that means because of this idea
called debt which doesn't even exist in
the physical reality
it's only part of a game that we've
invented
and yet the well-being of billions of
people is now being compromised
extreme layoffs tent cities accelerating
poverty austerity measures imposed
schools shutting down child hunger and
other levels of familial deprivation all
because of this elaborate fiction
what are we [__] stupid
hey hey Marge my man help a brother out
huh
grow up kids
[Music]
Saturn what's up man you remember that
smoking nebula I hooked you up with a
while back
uh listen ice we're getting really tired
of you you've been given everything and
yet you waste it all yeah you got plenty
of resources and you know it why don't
you grow up and learn some
responsibility for Christ's sake you're
making your mother miserable
[Music]
you're on your own pal
yeah whatever
[Music]
now all of this considered from the
waste machine known as the market system
to the debt machine known as the
monetary system hence creating the
monetary Market Paradigm which defines
the global economy today
there is one consequence that runs
through the entire machine
inequality
whether it is the market system which
creates a natural gravitation towards
Monopoly and power consolidation while
also generating pockets of wealthy
industries that Tower over others
regardless of utility such as the fact
that top hedge fund managers on Wall
Street now take home over 300 million
dollars a year for contributing
literally nothing
while a scientist looking for a cure for
a disease trying to help Humanity might
make sixty thousand dollars a year if
they're lucky
or whether it is the monetary system
which has class division built right
into its structure
for example if I have one million
dollars to spare and I put it into a CD
at four percent interest I will make
forty thousand dollars a year no social
contribution no nothing
however if I'm a lower class person and
have to take loans to buy my car or home
I am paying in interest which in
abstraction is going to pay that
millionaire with the four percent CD
this stealing from the poor to pay the
rich is a foundational built-in aspect
of the monetary system and it could be
labeled structural classes
of course historically social
stratification has always been deemed
unfair but obviously accepted overall as
now one percent of the population owns
40 percent of the planet's wealth
but material fairness aside there is
something else going on underneath the
surface of inequality causing an
incredible deterioration in public
health as a whole
well I think people often uh puzzled by
the contrast between the material
success of our societies unprecedented
levels of wealth
and the many social failings I mean you
know if you look at the the rates of um
drug abuse or violence or self-harm
amongst kids or mental illness there's
clearly something going deeply wrong
with our societies what the data that
I've been describing does
is simply shows that intuition that we
people have had for hundreds of years
that inequality is divisive and socially
corrosive that that intuition is truer
than I think we ever imagined
there are very powerful psychological
and social effects of inequality more to
do I suppose with feelings of in of
superiority and inferiority that kind of
division and and maybe going with the
sort of respect disrespect people
feeling looked down on at the bottom
which by the way is why violence is more
common in more unequal societies it's
the trigger to violence is so often
people feeling looked down on and
disrespected if there is one principle I
can emphasize
that is the most important
principle underlying the prevention of
violence
it would be equality
single most significant factor that
affects the rate of violence is the
degree of equality versus the degree of
inequality in that Society
that is a sort of General Social
dysfunction it's not just one or two
things that go wrong as inequality
increases it seems to be everything
whether we're talking about crime or
health or mental illness or whatever one
of the really disturbing findings out in
public health there is
never ever make the mistake of being
poor or being born poor your health pays
for an endless sorts of ways something
known as the health socioeconomic
gradient As you move down from the
highest strata in society in terms of
socioeconomic status every step down
Health gets worse for umpteen different
diseases life expectancy gets worse
infant mortality rate everything you
could look at so a huge issue has been
why is it that this grading exists
totally simple obvious answer which is
if you were chronically sick you're not
going to be very productive so Health
causes Drive socioeconomic differences
not that in the slightest on the very
simple level that you could look at
socioeconomic status of a 10 year old
and that's going to predict something
about their health decades later so
that's the direction of causality next
one what's it about oh it's perfectly
obvious poor people can't afford to go
to the doctor it's Healthcare access
it's got nothing to do with that because
you see these same gradients in
countries with universal health care
socialized medicine okay next simple
explanation oh on the average the poorer
you are the more likely you are to smoke
to drink to all sorts of Lifestyle risk
factor stuff yeah those contribute but
careful Studies have shown that explains
maybe about a third of the variability
so what's left and what's left is having
a ton to do with the stress of poverty
so the poorer you are starting off being
you know the person who's one dollar
income behind Bill Gates the poorer you
are in this country on the average the
worse your health is this tells us
something really important the health
connection with poverty it's not about
being poor it's about feeling poor
increasingly we recognize that
chronic stress is an important influence
on health but the most important sources
of stress are the quality of social
relations and if there is anything that
lowers the quality of social relations
it is the socioeconomic stratification
of society
what science has now shown is that
regardless of material wealth the stress
of Simply living in a stratified Society
leads to a vast spectrum of public
health problems and the greater the
inequality the worse they become
life expectancy longer and more equal
countries
drug abuse
Less in more equal countries
mental illness
Social Capital meaning the ability of
people to trust each other
naturally greater in more equal
countries educational schools higher in
more equal countries homicide rates Less
in more equal countries crime and rates
of imprisonment
Less in more equal countries it goes on
and on infant mortality obesity teen
birth rate less and more equal countries
and perhaps most interesting Innovation
greater in more equal countries which
challenges the age-old notion that a
competitive stratified Society is
somehow more creative and inventive
moreover a study done in the UK called
the Whitehall study confirmed that there
is a social distribution of disease as
you go from the top of the socioeconomic
ladder to the bottom for example it was
found that the lowest rungs of the
hierarchy had a four-fold increase of
heart disease-based mortality compared
to the highest rungs and this pattern
exists irrespective of Access to Health
Care
hence the worse a person's relative
financial status the worse their health
is going to be on average
this phenomenon is rooted in what could
be termed psychosocial stress and it is
at the foundation of the greatest social
distortions plaguing our society today
its cause the monetary market system
make no mistake
the greatest destroyer of ecology the
greatest source of waste and depletion
and pollution
the greatest purveyor of violence War
crime poverty animal abuse and
inhumanity the greatest generator is
social and personal neuroses mental
disorders depression anxiety
not to mention the greatest source of
social paralysis stopping us from moving
into new methodologies for personal
health Global sustainability and
progress on this planet
is not some corrupt government or
legislation
not some Rogue Corporation or banking
cartel
not some flaw of human nature
and not some secret hidden cabal that
controls the world
it is in fact the socioeconomic system
itself at its very Foundation
foreign
[Music]
let's imagine for a moment we had the
option to redesign human civilization
from the ground up what if
hypothetically speaking we discovered an
exact replica of the planet Earth and
the only difference between this new
planet and our current one is that human
evolution had not occurred it was an
open palette no countries no cities no
pollution no Republicans just to
pristine open environment
so what would we do
well first we need a goal right and it's
safe to say that goal would be to
survive and not to just survive but to
do so in an optimized healthy prosperous
way most people indeed desire to live
and they would prefer to do so without
suffering therefore the basis of this
civilization needs to be as supportive
and hence sustainable for human life as
possible taking into account the
material needs of all the world's people
while trying to remove anything that
could hurt us in the long run
that goal of say maximum sustainability
understood the next question regards our
method what kind of approach do we take
well let's see last I checked politics
was the method of social operation on
Earth so what do the doctrines of the
Republicans liberals conservatives or
socialists have to say about societal
design
hmm
not a damn thing
okay then what about religion surely the
great Creator had to have left some
blueprints somewhere
no nothing I can find
okay then so what's left it appears
something called science science is
unique in that its methods demand not
only that the ideas proposed to be
tested and replicated but everything
science comes up with is also inherently
falsifiable in other words unlike
religion and politics science has no ego
and everything it suggests accepts the
possibility of being proven wrong
eventually
it holds on to nothing and evolves
constantly
well that sounds natural enough to me so
then based on the current state of
scientific knowledge in the early 21st
century along with our goal of Maximum
sustainability for the human population
how do we begin the actual process of
construction
well the first question to ask what do
we need to survive
the answer of course are planetary
resources whether it is the water we
drink the energy we use the raw
materials we utilize to create tools and
shelter the planet hosts an inventory of
resources many of which are demanded for
our survival
so given that reality it then becomes
critical to figure out what we have and
where it is
this means we need to conduct a survey
we simply locate and identify every
physical resource on the planet we can
along with the amount available at each
location from the deposits of copper to
the most potent locations for wind farms
to produce energy to the Natural
freshwater Springs to an assessment of
the amount of fish in the ocean to the
most Prime arable land for food
cultivation
Etc
but since we humans are going to be
consuming these resources over time we
then realize that not only do we need to
locate and identify we also need to
track
we need to make sure we don't run out of
any of this stuff that would be bad and
this means not only tracking our rates
of use but the rates of Earthly
regeneration as well
such as how long it takes for say a tree
to grow or a spring to replenish
this is called dynamic equilibrium
in other words if we use up trees faster
than they can be grown back we have a
serious problem for it is unsustainable
so then how do we track this inventory
especially when we recognize that all of
this stuff is scattered everywhere
we have large mineral mines in what we
call Africa energy concentrations in the
Middle East huge tidal power
possibilities on the Atlantic coast of
North America the largest supply of
fresh water in Brazil
Etc
well once again good old science has a
suggestion it's called systems theory
systems theory recognizes that the
fabric of the natural world from human
biology to the Earthly biosphere to the
gravitational pull of the solar system
itself is one huge synergistically
connected system fully interlinked
just as human cells connect to form our
organs and the organs connect to form
our bodies and since our bodies cannot
live without the Earthly resources of
food air and water we are intrinsically
connected to the Earth and so on
so as nature suggests we take all of
this inventory and tracking data and
create a system to manage it a global
resource management system in fact to
account for every relevant resource on
the planet there is simply no logical
alternative if our goal as a species is
survival in the long run we have to keep
track as a whole
that understood we can now consider
production how do we use all this stuff
what will our process of production be
and what do we need to consider to make
sure it is as optimized as possible to
maximize our sustainability
well the first thing that jumps right
out at us is the fact that we need to
constantly try and preserve the planet's
resources are essentially finite so it
is important that we be strategic
strategic preservation is key
the second thing we recognize is that
some resources are really not as good as
others in their performance in fact some
of this stuff when put into use has a
terrible effect on the environment which
invariably hinders our own health
for example oil and fossil fuels no
matter how you cut it release some
pretty destructive agents into the
environment therefore it is critical we
do our best to use such things only when
we really have to if at all fortunately
for us we see a ton of solar wind tidal
wave heat differential and geothermal
possibilities for energy production so
we can strategize objectively about what
we use and where to avoid what could be
called negative retro actions or
anything that results from production or
use that damages the environment and
hence ourselves
we will call this strategic safety to
couple in with our strategic
preservation
but production strategies do not stop
there we are going to need an efficiency
strategy for the actual mechanics of
production itself and what we find is
that there are roughly three specific
protocols we must adhere to
one every good we produce must be
designed to last as long as possible
naturally the more things break down the
more resources we are going to need to
replace them and the more waste produced
two when things do break down or are no
longer usable for whatever reason it is
critical that we Harvest or recycle as
much as we possibly can
so the production design must take this
into account directly at the very
earliest stages
three quickly evolving Technologies such
as Electronics which are subject to the
fastest rates of technological
obsolescence would need to be designed
to foreshadow and accommodate physical
updates
the last thing we want to do is throw
away an entire computer system just
because it has only one broken part or
is outdated so we simply design the
components to be easily updated part by
part standardized and universally
interchangeable foreshadowed by the
current trend of technological change
and when we realize that the mechanisms
of strategic preservation strategic
safety and strategic efficiency are
purely technical considerations devoid
of any human opinion or bias we simply
program these strategies into a computer
which can weigh and calculate all the
relevant variables allowing us to always
arrive at the absolute best method for
sustainable production based on current
understandings
and while that might sound complex all
it is is a glorified calculator not to
mention such multivariate
decision-making and monitoring systems
are already used across the world today
for isolated purposes it is simply a
process of scaling it out
so now we not only have our resource
management system but also a production
management system
both of which are easily computer
automated to maximize efficiency
preservation and safety
the informational reality is that the
human mind or even a group of humans
cannot track what needs to be tracked it
must be done by computers and it can be
and this brings us to the next level
distribution what sustainability
strategies make sense here well since we
know that the shortest distance between
two points is a straight line and since
energy is required to power transport
machines the less transport distance the
more efficient
producing Goods in one continent and
shipping them over to another only makes
sense if the goods in questions simply
cannot be produced in the Target area
otherwise it is nothing but wasteful
we must localize production so
distribution is simple fast and requires
the least amount of energy we'll call
this the proximity strategy which simply
means we reduce the travel of goods as
much as possible whether raw materials
or finished consumer products
of course it might also be important to
know what goods we are transporting and
why and This falls under the category of
demand
and demand is simply what people need to
be healthy and to have a high quality of
life
the spectrum of material human needs
range from core life-supporting
Necessities such as food Clean Water
Shelter to Social and recreational Goods
which allow for relaxation and personal
social enjoyment both important factors
in human and social health overall
so very simply we take another survey
people describe their needs demand is
assessed and production begins based on
that demand
and since the level of demand of
different Goods will naturally fluctuate
and change around different regions we
need to create a demand distribution
tracking system So to avoid overruns and
shortages
of course this idea is old news it is
used in every major store chain today to
make sure they keep up with their
inventory only this time we are tracking
on a global scale
but wait a minute we really can't fully
understand demand if we don't account
for the actual usage of the good itself
is it logical and sustainable for every
single human to say have one of
everything made regardless of their
usage
no that would be simply wasteful and
inefficient if a person has a need for a
good but that need is only for say 45
minutes a day on average it would be
much more efficient if that good was
made available to them and to others
when needed
many forget that it isn't the good that
they want it is the purpose of that good
when we realize that the good itself is
only as important as its utility we see
that external restriction or what we
might call today ownership is extremely
wasteful and environmentally illogical
in a fundamental economic sense
so we need to devise a strategy called
strategic access
this would be the foundation of our
demand distribution tracking system
which makes sure we can meet the demand
of the population's needs for Access of
whatever they need when they need it
and as far as physically obtaining the
goods centralized and Regional access
centers all make sense for the most part
placed in close proximity to the
population and a person would simply
come in take the item use it and when
finished return it when it is no longer
needed sort of how a library works today
in fact these centers could not only
exist in the community and the way we
see local stores today but specialized
access centers would exist in specific
areas where often certain goods are
utilized saving more energy with less
repeat transport
and once this demand tracking system is
in order it is tied into our production
management system and of course into our
resource management system hence
creating a unified dynamically updating
global economic management machine that
simply makes sure we remain sustainable
starting with securing the Integrity of
our finite resources moving to make sure
we only create the best most strategic
Goods possible while Distributing
everything in the most intelligent and
efficient way
and the unique result of this
preservation-based approach which is
intuitively counter to many
is that this logical ground up empirical
process of preservation and efficiency
which can only Define true human
sustainability on this planet
would likely enable something never
before seen in human history
access abundance
not just for a percentage of the global
population but the entire civilization
this economic model as was just
generalized this responsible systems
approach to Total Earth resource
management and processes designed again
to do nothing less than take care of
humanity as a whole in the most
efficient and sustainable way
could be termed a resource-based economy
the idea was defined in the 1970s by
structural engineer Jacques Fresco he
understood back then that Society was on
a collision course with nature and
itself unsustainable on every level and
if things didn't change we would destroy
ourselves one way or another
are all these things you're saying
Jacques could they be built with what we
know today or are some of these things
are you guessing based on what we know
today no all of these things can be
built with what we know today it would
take 10 years to change the surface of
the Earth to rebuild the world into a
second Garden of Eden the choice lies
with you the stupidity of a nuclear arms
race the development of weapons trying
to solve your problems politically by
electing this political party or that
political party that all politics is
immersed in corruption let me say it
again communism socialism fascism the
Democrats the Liberals we want to absorb
human beings all organizations that
believe in a better life of man there
are no negro problems or polish problems
or Jewish problems or Greek problems or
women's problems they're human problems
I'm not afraid of anybody I don't work
for anyone no one can discharge me I
have no boss I am afraid to live in the
society we live in today our society
cannot be maintained by by this type of
incompetency it was great the free
enterprise system about 35 years ago
that was the last of its usefulness now
we've got to change our way of thinking
or perish
the horror movies of the future of the
our society the way it didn't work
and politics would be part of a horror
movie
lots of people today use the term cold
science
because they're analytical
and they don't even know what analytical
means science means closer
approximations of the way the world
really works
so it's telling the truth is what it is
a scientist doesn't try to get along
with people they tell them what their
findings are they have to question all
things and if some scientist comes up
with an experiment that shows certain
materials have certain strength other
scientists have to be able to duplicate
that experiment and come up with the
same results
even if a scientist feels that an
airplane wing due to mathematics or
calculations can hold up a given amount
of weight they still pile sandbags on it
to see when it breaks and they say you
know my calculations are right or
they're not correct I love that system
because it's free of bias and free of
thinking that math can solve all the
problems you have to put your math to
test also I think that every system that
can be put to test should be put to test
and they're all decisions should be
based upon research
a resource-based economy is simply the
scientific method applied to social
concern an approach utterly absent in
the world today
Society is a technical invention and the
most efficient methods of optimized
human health physical production
distribution City infrastructure and the
like reside in the field of science and
technology not politics or monetary
economics it operates in the same
systematic way as say an airplane and
there is no Republican or liberal way to
build an airplane
likewise nature itself is the physical
referent we use to prove our science and
it is a set system emerging only from
our increased understanding of it in
fact it has no regard for what you
subjectively think or believe to be true
rather it gives you an option you can
learn and fall in line with its natural
laws and conduct yourself accordingly
invariably creating good health and
sustainability
or you can go against the current to no
avail
it doesn't matter how much you believe
you can just stand up right now and walk
on the wall next to you the law of
gravity will not allow it if you do not
eat you will die if you are not touched
as an infant you will die
as harsh as it may sound nature is a
dictatorship and we can either listen to
it and come in harmony with it or suffer
the inevitable adverse consequences
so a resource-based economy is nothing
more than a set of proven
life-supporting understandings where all
decisions are based upon optimized human
and environmental sustainability
it takes into account the empirical life
ground which every human being shares as
a need regardless again of their
political or religious philosophy
there is no cultural relativism to this
approach it isn't a matter of opinion
human needs are human needs and having
access to the necessities of life such
as clean air nutritious food and clean
water along with a positively
reinforcing stable nurturing and
non-violent environment is demanded for
our mental and physical health our
evolutionary Fitness and hence the
species survival itself
a resource-based economy
would be based upon available resources
you can't just bring a lot of people to
an island or build a city of 50 000
people without having access to the
necessities of life so when I use the
term a comprehensive systems approach
I'm talking about doing an inventory of
the area first and determining what that
area can supply not just architectural
approach not just design approach but
design must be based on all of the
requirements to enhance human life and
that's what I mean by an integrated way
of thinking food clothing shelter warms
love all those things are necessary
if you deprive people of any of them you
have a lesser human being less capable
of functioning
as previously outlined a resource-based
economy is ground-up Global Systems
approach to extraction production and
distribution is based upon a set of true
economic mechanisms or strategies which
guarantee efficiency and sustainability
in every area of the economy
so continuing this train of thought
regarding logical design what is next in
our equation where does all this
materialize
cities
the Advent of the city is a defining
feature of modern civilization its role
is to enable efficient access to the
necessities of life along with increased
social support and Community interaction
so how we go about designing an ideal
city
what shape should we make it Square
trapezoid well given we're going to be
moving around the thing we might as well
make it as equidistant as possible for
ease hence the circle
what should the city contain well
naturally we need a residential area a
Goods production area a power generation
area an agricultural area but we also
need nurturing as human beings hence
culture nature Recreation and education
so let's include a nice open Park an
entertainment events area for cultural
purposes and socializing and educational
and research facilities and since we're
working with a circle it seems rational
to place these functions in belts based
on the amount of land required for each
goal along with ease of access very good
now let's get down to specifics first we
need to consider the core infrastructure
or intestines of the city organism these
would be the water good waste and energy
transport channels just as we have water
and sewage systems under our cities
today we would extend this channeling
concept to integrate waste recycling and
delivery itself
no more mailman or garbage men it is
built right in we could even use
automated pneumatic tubes and similar
Technologies
Sam goes for transport it needs to be
integrated and strategically designed to
reduce or even remove the need for
wasteful independent automobiles
electric trams conveyors transveres and
maglevs which can take you virtually
anywhere in the city even up and down
along with connecting you to other
cities as well
and of course in the event an automobile
is required it is automated by satellite
for safety and integrity in fact this
automation technology is in working
order right now automobile accidents
kill about 1.2 million people every
single year injuring about 50 million
this is absurd and doesn't have to occur
between efficient City design and
automated driverless cars this death
toll can be virtually eliminated
agriculture
today through our haphazard cost cutting
industrial methods using pesticides
excessive fertilizers and other means we
have successfully destroyed much of the
arable land on this planet not to
mention also extensively poisoning our
bodies in fact industrial and
agricultural chemical toxins now show up
in virtually every human being tested
including infants
fortunately there's a glaring
alternative the soilless mediums of
Hydroponics and aeroponics which also
reduce nutrient and water requirements
by up to 75 percent of our current usage
food can now be organically grown on an
industrial scale in enclosed vertical
Farms such as in 50-story one acre plots
virtually eliminating the need for
pesticides and hydrocarbons in general
this is the future of industrial food
cultivation efficient clean and abundant
so such Advanced systems would be in
part what comprise our agricultural belt
producing all the food required for the
entire City's population with no need to
import anything from the outside saving
time waste and energy
and speaking of energy
the energy build would work in a systems
approach to extract electricity from our
abundant renewable mediums specifically
wind solar geothermal and heat
differentials and if near water
potentials tidal and wave power
to avoid intermittency and make sure a
positive net energy return occurs these
mediums would operate in an integrated
system powering each other when needed
while storing excessive energy to large
super capacitors under the ground so
nothing can go to waste
and not only does the city power itself
particular structures will also power
independently and generate electricity
through photovoltaic paints structural
pressure transducers the thermocouple
effect and other current but
underutilized Technologies
but of course this begs the question how
does this technology and goods in
general get created in the first place
this brings us to production the
industrial belt apart from having
hospitals and the like would be the Hub
of factory production completely
localized overall it would of course
obtain raw materials by way of the
global resource management system just
discussed with Demand Being generated by
the population of the city itself
as far as the mechanics of production we
need to discuss a new powerful
phenomenon which was sparked very
recently in human history and is on Pace
to changing everything
it's called mechanization or the
automation of Labor
well if you look around you you'll
notice that almost everything that we
use today
is built automatically your shoes your
clothes your home appliances your car
and so on
they are all built by machines in an
automatic way
can we say that the society has not been
influenced by these major technological
advancements
of course not these systems really
dictate new structures
and new needs and they make a lot of
other things obsolete so we've been
going up in the development and use of
technology in an exponential way so
definitely automation is going to
continue you cannot stop
the technologies that just make sense
labor automation through technology is
at the bottom of every major social
transformation in human history from the
Agricultural Revolution and the
invention of the plow to the Industrial
Revolution and the invention of the
powered machine to the information age
we live in now through essentially the
invention of advanced electronics and
computers
and with regard to Advanced production
methods today mechanization is now
evolving on its own moving away from the
traditional method of assembling
component parts into a configuration
into an advanced method of creating
entire products in one single process
but like most Engineers I'm fascinated
by biology because it's so full of
examples of extraordinary pieces of
engineering and absolutely what biology
is is the study of things that copy
themselves across
go to definition of life as we've got
again as an engineer I've always been
intrigued by the idea of machines that
will cover themselves
red wrap is a three-dimensional printer
that's to say it's a printer that you
plug into a computer and instead of
making two-dimensional sheets of paper
with patterns on it makes real physical
three-dimensional objects now there's
nothing new about that 3D printers have
been around for about 30 Years big thing
about reprap is that it prints most of
its own parts
so if you've got one you can make
another one and give it to a friend as
well as being able to print lots of
useful things
from the simple printing of basic
household goods in your home to the
printing of an entire automobile body in
one swoop Advanced automated 3D printing
now has the potential to transform
virtually every field of production
including home construction
Contour crafting is actually a
fabrication technology
so-called 3D printing when you directly
build a 3D object from a computer model
using Contour crafting it will be
possible to build a 2000 square foot
home
entirely by the machine in one day
the reason that people are interested in
automating construction is that it
really brings a lot of benefits for
example construction is pretty labor
intensive and although it provides job
for a sector of the society but also has
issues and complications for example
construction is the most dangerous job
that there is it is worse than Mining
and agriculture it has got the highest
level of fatality almost in every
country
another issue is the waste an average
home United States has three to seven
tons of waste
so this is huge if we look at the impact
of construction and knowing that about
40 percent of all materials in the world
are used in construction so a big waste
of energy and resources and big damage
to the environment as well making homes
using Hammers and nails and wood with
the state of our technology today is
really absurd and will go the way of our
labor class in regards to Manufacturing
in the United States recently there was
a study by Economist David attour of MIT
that states that our middle class is
Obsolete and being replaced by
automation
quite simply mechanization is more
productive efficient and sustainable
than human labor in virtually every
sector of the economy today
machines do not need vacations brakes
Insurance pensions and they can work 24
hours a day every day
the output potential and accuracy
compared to human labor is unmatched
the bottom line repetitive human labor
is becoming obsolete and impractical
across the world and the unemployment
you see around you today is
fundamentally the result of this
evolution of efficiency in technology
for years Market economists have
dismissed this growing pattern which
could be called technological
unemployment because of the fact that
new sectors always seem to emerge to
reabsorb the displaced workers
today the service sector is the only
real Hub left and currently employs over
80 percent of the American Workforce
with most industrialized countries
maintaining a similar proportion however
this sector is now being challenged
increasingly by automated kiosks
automated restaurants and even automated
stores
economists today are finally
acknowledging what they have been
denying for years not only is
technological unemployment exasperating
the current labor crisis we see across
the world due to the global economic
downturn
but the more the recession deepens the
faster the industries are mechanizing
the catch which is not realized is that
the faster they mechanize to save money
the more they displace people the more
they reduce public purchasing power
this means that while the corporation
can produce everything more cheaply
fewer and fewer people will actually
have money to buy anything regardless of
how cheap they become
the bottom line is that the labor for
income game is slowly coming to an end
in fact if you take a moment to reflect
on the jobs which are in existence today
which automation could take over right
now if applied 75 percent of the global
Workforce could be replaced by
mechanization tomorrow
and this is why in a resource-based
economy there is no monetary market
system
no money at all so there is no need a
resource-based economy recognizes the
efficiency of mechanization and accepts
it for what it offers it doesn't fight
it like we do today why because it is
irresponsible not to given any interest
in efficiency and sustainability
and this brings us back to our city
system
in the center is the central dome which
not only houses the educational
facilities and Transportation Hub it
also hosts the Mainframe that runs the
city's technical operations the city is
in fact one big Automated machine it has
sensors in all technical belts to track
the progress of Agriculture energy
Gathering production distribution and
the light
now would people be needed to oversee
these operations in the event of a
malfunction or the like most probably
yes but that number would decrease over
time as improvements continue
however as of today maybe three percent
of the city population would be needed
for this job when you break it down
and I can assure you that in an economic
system which is actually designed to
take care of you and secure your
well-being without you having to submit
to a private dictatorship on a daily
basis usually to a job that is either
technically unnecessary or socially
pointless while often struggling with
debt that doesn't exist just to make
ends meet
I guarantee you people will volunteer
their time left and right to maintain
and improve A system that actually takes
care of them
and coupled with this issue of incentive
comes the common assumption that if
there isn't some external pressure for
one to work for a living people will
just sit around do nothing and turn into
fat lazy blobs
this is nonsense
the labor system we have today is in
fact the generator of laziness not a
resolver of it
if you think back to when you're a child
full of life interested in new things to
understand likely creating and exploring
But as time went on the system pushed
you into the focus of figuring out how
to make money
and from Early Education to study at a
university you are narrowed only to
emerge as a creature which serves as a
cog in a wheel in a model that sends all
the fruits to the upper one percent
scientific Studies have now shown that
people are in fact not motivated by
monetary reward when it comes to
Ingenuity and creation
the creation itself is the reward money
in fact appears only to serve as an
incentive for repetitive mundane actions
a role we have just now shown can be
replaced by machine
so when it comes to Innovation the
actual use of the human mind the
monetary incentive has proven to be a
hindrance interfering and detracting
from creative thought
and this might explain why Nikola Tesla
the Wright brothers and other inventors
who contributed massively to our current
world never showed a monetary incentive
to do so
money is in fact a false incentive and
causes a hundred times more Distortion
than it does contribution
[Music]
please settle down the first thing I
would like to do is go around the room
and ask what everyone would like to be
when they grow up
who'd like to go first
okay how about you Sarah
when I grow up I want to work in
McDonald's like my mom oh family
tradition eh how about you Linda when I
grow up I'm gonna be a prostitute on the
streets of New York City
oh glamor girl huh very ambitious how
about you Tommy when I grow up I'm gonna
be a rich elitist business fan who works
on Wall Street and profits off of the
collapse of foreign economies
enterprising and great to see some
Multicultural interest
[Music]
as stated before a resource-based
economy applies the scientific method to
social concern and this isn't limited to
Simply technical efficiency
it also has the consideration of human
and social well-being directly and what
comprises it what good is a social
system if in the end it doesn't produce
happiness and peaceful coexistence so it
is important to point out that with the
removal of the money system and the
necessities of life provided we would
see a global reduction in crime by about
95 percent almost immediately for there
is nothing to steal embezzle scam or the
like
95 percent of all people in prisons
today are there due to some monetary
related crime or drug abuse and drug
abuse is a disorder not a crime
so what about the other five percent the
truly violent often seeming to some as
being violent for the sake of being
violent are they just evil people
the the reason that I
frankly think it's a waste of time to
engage in moral value judgments about
people's violence is because it doesn't
Advance by one iota our understanding of
either the causes or the prevention of
the violent Behavior people sometimes
ask if I believe in forgiving criminals
my answer to that is no I don't believe
in forgiveness any more than I believe
in condemnation it's only if we as a
society can take the same attitude of
treating violence as a problem in public
health and preventive medicine rather
than as a moral evil
it's only when we make that change and
our own attitudes and assumptions and
values though we will actually succeed
in reducing the level of violence rather
than stimulating it which is what we do
now
the more Justice you seek the more hurt
you become because there's no such thing
as Justice there is whatever there is
out there that's it in other words if
people are conditioned to be racist and
bigots if they're brought up in an
environment that Advocates that why do
you blame the person for IT they're a
victim of a subculture
therefore they have to be helped
the point is we have to redesign the
environment that produces aberrant
Behavior that's the problem not putting
a person in jail that's why judges
lawyers Freedom of Choice such concepts
are dangerous because it gives you
misinformation that the person is bad or
that person is a serial killer serial
killers are made just like soldiers
become serial killers with a machine gun
that become the killing machines but
nobody looks at them as murderers or
assassins because that's natural
so we blame people we say well this guy
was a Nazi he taught the Jews no he was
brought up to torture Jews once you
accept the fact that people have
individual choices and they're free to
make those choices free to make choices
means without being influenced and I
can't understand that at all all of us
are influenced in all our choices by the
culture we live in by our parents and by
the values that dominate so we're
influenced so they can't be free choices
what's the greatest country in the world
the two answer I haven't been all over
the world and I don't know I will know
enough about different cultures to
answer that question
I don't know anybody that speaks that
way as I good old USA the greatest
country alone there's no survey have you
been to India no you've been to England
though I've been to France no uh what do
you make your assumptions on they can't
answer they get mad at you as well God
damn it who the hell are you to tell me
what to say yeah don't forget you're
dealing with aberrated people they're
not responsible for their answers
they're victims of culture that means
they've been influenced by their culture
foreign
[Music]
there are often a number of arguments
that tend to come up with regards to the
efficiency hey hey
um now hold on just a minute yes I know
what this is this is called Marxism
buddy
Stalin killed 800 billion people because
of ideas like this my father died
[Music]
and as the irrationality of the audience
grew shocked and Confused suddenly the
narrator suffered a fatal heart attack
and the seemingly communist propaganda
film was no more
foreign
[Music]
to people in Think Tank type of
situations and you know these Club of
Rome types and so forth
where did that come
from they just they got this icon they
hold on to it's their Holy Grail
and it's such an easy one you know
people ask if I'm a socialist or a
communist or a capitalist and I say I'm
none of the above and why do you think
why do you think that those are the only
options all of those political
constructs were created by writers who
assumed that we lived on a planet of
infinite resources not a one of those
political philosophies even con
contemplates that there might be a
shortage of anything I believe that
communism socialism free enterprise
fascism are part of social Evolution
that you can't take a giant step from
one culture to another but they're in
between systems before there's any ISM
we've got a life ground and the life
ground is as I just described most
easily that's all the conditions
required to take your next breath and
that involves the air you breathe the
water you get the safety you have the
education you can access all these
things that we share and use and that no
life in any culture can do without so
we've got to reset down to the life
ground and the life ground is no longer
any ISM it's life value analysis
it's simply a matter of historical fact
that the dominant intellectual culture
of any particular society reflects the
interest of the dominant group in that
Society
in a slave owning Society the beliefs
about human beings and human rights and
so on will reflect the needs of the
slave owners in a society which again is
based on the power of certain people to
control and profit from the lives and
work of millions of others the dominant
intellectual culture will reflect the
needs of of the dominant group and so
that if you look across the board the
ideas that pervade psychology and
sociology and history and political
economy and political science
fundamentally reflects certain Elite
interests and the academics who question
that too much
tend to get shunted to the side or to be
seen as sort of radicals
the dominant values of a culture tend to
support and perpetuate what is rewarded
by that culture
and in a society where success and
status is measured by material wealth
not social contribution it is easy to
see why the state of the world is what
it is today
we are dealing with a value system
disorder completely denatured where the
priority of personal and social health
have become secondary to the detrimental
Notions of artificial wealth and
Limitless growth
and like a virus this disorder now
permeates every facet of government news
media entertainment and even Academia
and built into its structure are
mechanisms of protection from anything
that might interfere
Disciples of the monetary Market
religion the self-appointed Guardians of
the status quo constantly seek out ways
to avoid any form of thought which might
interfere with their beliefs the most
common of which are projected dualities
if you are not a republican you must be
a Democrat if you are not a Christian
you might be a Satanist and if you feel
Society can be greatly improved to
consider perhaps I don't know taking
care of everyone you're just a
utopianist and the most Insidious of
them all if you are not for the free
market you must be against Freedom
itself
I'm a Believer believer in Freedom
every time you hear the word Freedom
being said anywhere or government's
interference said anywhere it means
decoded
blocking maximization of turning money
into more money for private money
possessors
that's it every other thing they'll say
oh we need more Commodities from people
all this uh Freedom against tyranny and
so forth every time you see it you can
decode it down to that and I think
you'll find a one-to-one correlation
with every time they use it and this is
the sense in which we might call
it's a syntax a governing syntax of
understanding and of value
so that it governs beneath their own
recognition of it so they may not say oh
I didn't mean that at all but in fact
that's what they do just like you may
speak a grammar and you have rules of
grammar you follow without recognizing
what the rules are and so what we have
is what I call the ruling value syntax
that underlies this so every time they
use these words government interference
lack of Freedom or Freedom or progress
or development you can decode them all
to come back to mean that
of course when you hear the word Freedom
it tends to be in the same sentence with
something called democracy it's
fascinating how people today seem to
believe that they actually have a
relevant influence on what their
government does forgetting that the very
nature of our system offers everything
for sale
the only vote that counts is the
monetary vote and it doesn't matter how
much any activist yells about ethics or
accountability in a market system every
politician every legislation and hence
every government is for sale
and even with the 20 trillion dollar
Bank bailout starting in 2007 an amount
of money which could have changed say
the global energy infrastructure to
fully renewable methods instead going to
a series of Institutions that literally
do nothing to help Society institutions
that could be removed tomorrow with no
recourse
blind conditioning that politics and
politicians exist for the public
well-being still continues
the fact is politics is a business no
different than any other in a market
system than they care about their
self-interest before anything else
I don't really honestly deep down
believe in political action I think the
system contracts and expands as it wants
to it accommodates these changes I think
the Civil Rights Movement was an
accommodation on the part of those who
own the country I think they see where
their self-interest lies they see a
certain amount of Freedom seems good an
illusion of Liberty give these people a
voting day every year so that they'll
have the illusion of meaningless Choice
meaningless choice that we go like
slaves and say John I voted the limits
of debate in this country are
established before the debate even
begins and everyone else is marginalized
they're made to seem either to be
Communists or with some sort of disloyal
person a kook there's a word and now
it's conspiracy see they've made that
something that should not be even
entertained for a minute that powerful
people might get together and have a
plan doesn't happen you're a kook you're
a conspiracy buff
and of all the mechanisms of Defense of
this system there are two that
repeatedly come up
the first is this idea that the system
has been the cause of the material
progress we have seen on this planet
well no
there are basically two root causes
which have created The increased
so-called wealth and population growth
we see today
one the exponential advancement of
production technology hence scientific
ingenuity
and two the initial discovery of
abundant hydrocarbon energy which is
currently the foundation of the entire
socioeconomic system
the free market capitalist monetary
market system whatever you want to call
it has done nothing but ride the wave of
these advents with the distorted
incentive system and a haphazard grossly
unequal method of utilizing and
distributing those fruits
the second defense is a belligerent
social bias generated from years of
propaganda which sees any other social
system as a route to so-called tyranny
with various name droppings of Stalin
Mao Hitler and the death tolls they
generated well as despotic as these men
might have been along with the societal
approaches they perpetuated when it
comes to the Game of Death when it comes
to the systematic daily mass murder of
human beings nothing in history compares
to what we have today
famines throughout at least the last
century of our history have not been
caused by a lack of food they've been
caused by relative poverty the economic
resources were so inequitably
distributed that the poor simply didn't
have enough money
with which to buy the food that would
have been available if they could have
afforded to pay for it
that would be an example of structural
violence
another example in Africa and some other
areas but I'll particularly focused on
Africa
tens of millions of people are dying of
AIDS why are they dying
it's not because we don't know how to
treat AIDS we have you know millions of
people in the in the wealthy countries
are getting along remarkably well
because they have the medicines that
will treat it the people in Africa who
are dying of AIDS are not dying because
of the HIV virus they're dying because
they don't have the money with which to
pay for the drugs that would keep them
alive Gandhi saw this he said the
deadliest form of violence
is poverty and that's absolutely right
poverty kills far more people than all
the war is in history more people than
all the murderers in history more than
all the suicides in history
not only does structural violence kill
more people than all the behavioral
violence put together
structural violence is also the main
cause of Behavioral violence
[Music]
oil is the foundation of and that is
present throughout the edifice of human
civilization there are 10 calories of
hydrocarbon energy oil and natural gas
and every calorie of food you and I eat
in the industrialized World fertilizers
are made from natural gas pesticides are
made from oil you drive oil-powered
machines to plant plow irrigate Harvest
transport package you wrap the food in
plastic that soil all plastic is oil
there are seven gallons of oil in every
Tire oil is everywhere it's ubiquitous
and it's only because of oil that there
are seven billion people or almost 7
billion people on this planet right now
the arrival of this cheap easy energy
which is equivalent by the way to
billions of slaves working around the
club
to change the world in such a radical
way over the last century and the
population has gone up 10 times but by
2050 the oil supply is able to support
less than half the present world's
population in their present way of life
so the scale of adjustment to live
differently is just enormous The World
Is Now using six barrels of oil for
every barrel it finds five years ago it
was using four barrels of oil for every
barrel it finds a year from now it's
going to be using eight barrels of oil
for every barrel it finds what's
disturbing to me is the lack of any real
efforts from governments worldwide or
industry leaders worldwide to do
something different I mean we have these
sort of attempts to build more wind
power and to maybe do something with
Thai we've got attempts to make our cars
a little bit more um efficient but
there's nothing which really looks like
a Revolution coming along there's a all
pretty minor and that I think is pretty
frightening and the governments who are
driven by these economists who don't
really appreciate what we're talking
about
are trying to stimulate consumerism to
restore past prosperity in the hope that
they can restore the past they're
printing yet more money lacking any
collateral at all so if if the economy
improves and recovers and growth famous
growth comes back it'll only be
short-lived because within a short
period of time counted in months rather
than Years it'll hit the supply barrier
again there'll be another price shock
and a deeper recession so I think we go
into a series of vicious circles so you
have the economic growth going up price
spike everything shuts down that's where
we are now then it starts to come up
again but what we have now is this is
this area where there's there's no more
ability to produce cheap energy we're at
the peak we're on the downslope of oil
production nowhere you're going to get
any more out of the ground any faster
which means that things shut down the
price of oil drops which it did in the
early 2009 but then as you have an erzot
so-called recovery the price of oil
starts to come back it's recently been
hovering around eighty dollars a barrel
and what we see is that eighty dollars a
barrel now with the economic and
financial collapse people are having a
hard time affording that we're alone
production right now is about 86 million
barrels a day
over 10 years you're looking at roughly
40 million barrels a day having to be
replaced there's nothing around which
can come even
within a one percent of meeting that
sort of demand if we don't do something
pretty quickly there's going to be a
huge energy deficiency I think the big
mistake is in not recognizing
um a decade or so ago that an effort a
concerted airport needed to be made to
develop these sustainable forms of
energy I think that's something our
grandchildren will look back on with
total
disbelief you people knew that you were
dealing with a finite commodity how
could you possibly have built your
economy around something which was going
to disappear for the first time in human
history the species is now faced with
the depletion of a core resource Central
to our current system of survival and
the punch line of the whole thing is
that even with oil becoming more and
more scarce the economic system will
still blindly push its cancerous growth
model so people can go out and buy more
oil-powered cars to generate GDP in jobs
exacerbating the decline
are there solutions to replace the
edifice of the hydrocarbon economy of
course
but the path needed to accomplish these
changes will not manifest through the
market system protocols required since
new Solutions can only be implemented
through the profit mechanism
people are not investing in renewable
energies because there is no money in it
in both a long and short term and the
commitment needed to make it happen can
only occur at a severe Financial loss
hence there is no monetary incentive and
in this system if there's no monetary
incentive things do not happen
and on top of it all peak oil is just
one of many surfacing consequences of
the environmental social train wreck
gaining speed today other declines
include fresh water the very fabric of
our existence which is currently showing
shortages for 2.8 billion people and
those shortages are on Pace to reach 4
billion by 2030.
food production the destruction of
arable crop land from which 99.7 percent
of all human food comes from today is
occurring up to 40 times faster than it
is being replenished and over the last
40 years 30 percent of the arable land
has become unproductive not to mention
that hydrocarbons are the backbone of
Agriculture today and as it declines so
will the food supply
as far as resources in general and our
current patterns of consumption by 2030
we will need two planets to continue our
rates not to mention the continual
destruction of Life supporting
biodiversity causing Extinction spasms
and environmental destabilization across
the globe and with all of these declines
we have the near exponential population
growth whereby 2030 there might be over
8 billion people on this planet
energy production alone would need to
increase 44 percent by 2030 to meet such
demand
and again since money is the only
initiator of action are we to expect
that any country on the planet is going
to be able to afford the massive changes
needed to revolutionize agriculture
water processing energy production and
the like when the global debt pyramid
scheme is slowly shutting the entire
world down not to mention the fact that
the unemployment you currently see is
going to become normality due to the
nature of technological unemployment the
jobs are not coming back
and finally a broad social perspective
from 1970 to 2010 poverty on this planet
doubled due to this system and given our
current state do you honestly think we
will see anything less than more
doubling more suffering and more mass
starvation
there is not going to be any recovery
this is not some long depression that
we're sudden someday gonna pull out of I
think the next phase we're going to see
after the next round of economic
collapse is massive civil unrest when
employment checks stop being paid
because the states have no money left
and when things get so bad that people
lose confidence and they're evicted
leaders they will demand change if we
don't kill each other in the process or
destroy the environment I'm just afraid
that we might get to the point of no
return
and that bothers me no end we do all we
can to avoid that condition
clear that we're on the verge of a great
transition in human life
that what we face now is this
fundamental change of the life we've
known over the last century
there has to be a link between the
economy and the resources of this planet
the resources being of course all animal
and plant life the health of the oceans
and everything else
this is a monetary Paradigm that will
not let go until it's killed the last
human being
the in-group will do all it can to stay
in power
and that's what you got to keep in mind
they'll use the Army and Navy and lies
or whatever they have to use to keep in
power they're not about to give it up
because they don't know of any other
system that will perpetuate their kind
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
take a straight and stronger course to
the corner of your life
[Music]
just remember that the goal
is for us all the capture
[Music]
squares
with love and care for yourself
[Applause]
time this time and time with your time
and its news is
captured
for the queen to use
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]